>>> E BACKTHE N.NATION'S TEAFICL
THE DIRE THE PANDEMIAS TSS.S.W,
WHEN
IT'S BECOME A
VERYD DE.
JOINING MES NEW HAMPSHIR
BLR CHRIS
IT'
WE BOT N
COS LKPEY E.
COVI IS TER WRAETS
EVRE.
WE HAVE IT FRO KENNEDYFROM JOE .
ISISYO IVES THINK MISINFORMATIO
CAUSING MASSIVE CONFUSION.
LIVES. TO SAY IT'S COSTING
E  HAVE IN SHIP POSITIOHAD A LOF
OM THE CDC
AND EVENIN SM MEDI TO IFE SUR A.
VACCINATION .              Y HI
IT'SRU, NEED TO RALLY YB TERMS
THE CsOU HAV
QUESTIONS,K TO YOUR DOCTOR.
I VERE EVERYONE THOUGHT IT
WHICH IS A VERY GOOD TNG
BUT IT DOEALA LITTLE OM
WE CAN'TE COMPLACENT.
HAVE BUMBLED SOMTS GHT
MESSAGING, BUTS T
SIUT.  WOULDT AT.
>> THERE A PNED
WHE.
DO YOUNK COMPANIES LIKSPOTIFY S
EFFORTO E LIKE THAT
FROM F TOOTHPASTE
O SAY WE'RE GOING  STOP PEOPLE .
WE MISINFORMGOING TO STOP R
IT'S FREE SPEECH.
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHIRVOICE AND T.
TH FINE.
TH'SM A LEADER PO
BE CRYSTAL CLEAR.
I WOULD NEVER SAC ONE HAS BEEN
THIS, 'RG TO DO THIS.WE'RE GOIN
WHENIBODIECOMEDAYS.
IMPORTANTR TE THE
MI THE MAY MEAN.
TO TOOLBOXTO GET US THROUGH THI
E OF I
WHAT YOU CAN SAY AA LEADER
YOUR FELLOW REICR UNGKIN OF VIR
WEAR MKS
IS THATHE ROACH RIGHNOW?
I'LL SAY IN NEW HAMWE'R.OWN STW
COCHOOLSTHE LO
PARENTS, SCHOOL BOARD, TEACHERS
HAVEF  T
WE LET THEM  THASION
MAYBE SOUTHERNREHESTER AND A BIL
MIGHT HAVE DIFFERENTES
ANLITY AND
DIFFERENT STTE
THAN A ONE-ROOSE I
YOU LET THAT FLEXILI
AT AEL, LET THPAREVOICE.ASTHEY T
OUT.
A ONE--FATE
SAYING EONMUST WA UST NOT THE WV
>> THE OITHAT ,
U CAN'AR
>> ALIEVE IN THE LOCAL
CONTROL.
THAT'S WHERE WREE.
T, A W
THIS
WEF THIS LIFT  T IN THINGS
ARE WE OUTF TH GOOD?LO TERM.
MA GOE
COMES B FALL.
AND THATN
>> I WANT TO ME
YOU SAY YOU DO
NEW HAMPSHIRE AND
YOU OBVIOUSLY E --  SAYIT  DIST.
L OULD HAVE THAR, BECASTEM IS DY
>> I WANT TOLAFROMT P
CONFERENCE.
HE REFERENCED COMMENCA. P E  QU
THITDOG  I J
OOCXT
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT ONY
THAT REPUBLICANS D STANDYTHING R
>> I DON'T APPRECIATE THIDENT UI
>> BECAUSE I CRITICAL OFTH SIDE
>> IT DOESN' YOU WEREN'T
NO.
OALO
FOES
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO STOP
LO THINK IT'
GOOD THEY STOP CIN SURE.
AS A GNOR, IT'S SUCH ADIFFERT
WEDOERS, MANAGERS, CREATIN
SOLUTIONS,RA-ONE WITH KI
FUCAN DO ME  PROTECT TNGING, VE
INTERESTS OF NEWPSHIRE AS A
GOI BELIEVE YOU NEED TO BALANC
I THER PS
MO AOST TY
PUBLICVI
IMMIGRATION, TNSUS
CAN FIND ON ANISSUROUND, WN U W
HE
REICS --
>> THERE WEREN'T ANY
CA TO ASK FO, TO
BE FAIR.
>> NO.
EY WERE SAYING WO HOLDHEE FOR TW
YOPOSED.
THAT.
T BIDEN --SURE AS HEIDN'T VOTEO
HIM.BUT WE ALLM TO
AND USE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITT
THE INFRASTU
>>EP.
Y DID BEATINMASTE CH TIME REACHH
COUPS
WORK WITH?AT'S WHAT
FRUSTRATION THAT MOSANS
COURT.ETE SU
PRESIDENDE NOMINATE A BLACKANO
GR>> NEVER FOR. BREYONRIY REPUBA
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING BODY T
COURT IS AS OP>> IS THIS A Q
>> I'LL SAASR I
AS.
YOU WANT GROUP WITH DI
SET  BUNDS.WOULDN'T GLE
OUT WANT SOMEBODY THATFFERENT P
MALE, WHATEVER IT
PECT
>> YOU'ROKAYH
TE A BLA
WO'S WHAT
S ROCESS SIDES
AS WE MO FORWARD.LD BE A CE BRE
SIDENT DONALD TRUMP
EOPLE WH
ANUARY
6th.
>> IF I RUANI E WILL
TROPJAFAIRLY
WE WILL TREAT THEM FY.
I
WI
EINGAT
UNFALYOUSP>> LOOK, THEOL
PART OF S AND THE ON.
TOE HELD
ERF  IT OFRNFA IN
, ITOL IN , EVERYONE NEEDS TO BH
AC
E ?
>> OF COUR.
OH, MY NO.
LIKAVE TH
R RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN
>> I DON'T ND
CAMPAIGN WITH ME.
I'M A BIG BELIEVER THA AS YOO S